[Music]
let's go to kira in sin jose california
kira what's going on
hey doctor john how are you
i'm rocking on man how are you i'm
pretty good very cool so what's up how
can i help yeah
um so my question i lost my mom about a
year ago to cancer wow
what kind of
cancer pancreatic cancer
quicken very awful very fast um yeah
very painful pretty
not fun way to go
um so sorry so
yeah yeah so it was kind of it was fast
it was um
shocking and then
so kind of in the so that was also kind
of right when
kovid was in the thick of things um you
know so
visiting was hard it was kind of scary i
work in healthcare
so a lot of just
worrying about
um everything exposing everything yeah
so then
yeah so kind of in the middle of that
i
found out i was pregnant
which was
um also a shock i had been told for a
long time that i would not be able to
have children
surprised all right surprise
and what better time to find out you're
pregnant than when your mom's slowly
passing away and there's a pandemic
going on and you work in health care
yeah
yeah so
a lot going on
hey hold on for a second have you just
stopped and went whoo
i
that's a lot
no no
not like um you haven't
it's a lot
that's a lot
yeah um okay so where are we now
babies baby here so yeah so baby is here
baby's doing great he's five months old
that's fun what's his name very oakley
oh beautiful i love it
okay so you got a five month old
yeah five months old my mom let's see so
she passed away in october
he was born in march um
it would have been her first grandkid
you know so she's uh
that hurts um so march before so
so he oh so he came just a few months
after she passed away yeah okay
[Music]
yeah and so
my question i guess is just
so so now i'm kind of at that point
where i'm moving past that
early grief um
like just kind of the shock of it all
and kind of just realizing like what
i've actually lost um
what my son has lost
um
you know it's like this is the rest of
my life she's not going to be here yeah
tell me what it feels like to say that
out loud
it hurts
what does that mean
it i mean honestly it just feels
hopeless um
just kind of empty like like what now
um
you know it's
it's like all i have a question and i
don't know who to ask
um you know and it's like questions that
i didn't know
you know when she was sick it was you
know we kind of had some conversations
like
if there's anything
you
want to ask me like now's the time to
ask me
um
but you don't think of something in the
moment you know it's like you think of
it later when it's too late yeah
and you're supposed to be able to text
your mom about diarrhea and rashes and
what diaper right you're supposed to
yeah
you know it's like
i was
one of those people who called my mom
every day you know it's like
we had a very good relationship um
so it just hurts so your mom was awesome
huh
yeah she was
she was yeah she would have been a
really great grandma too
so my dad is
i mean like my dad and i have a very
good relationship too
but he's obviously also going through
a big trauma yeah
um
and hey he's he's your dad yeah
and yeah it's different yeah yeah he
doesn't
he may be the best guy in the world
he's never carried a kid right yeah and
there's something about like i just want
my mom
yeah um and kind of on top of that he
had a traumatic brain injury a couple of
years ago
and so he's
it's like
he changed after that
um so he's still
like my dad he's still
there but his personality is not the
same
and then after this it's just kind of
like one more thing
so
it's just hard
so we i don't know you know
do me a favor take as deep a breath as
you can and just hold it for a second
three yeah two and then let it all out
say these words out loud
this
is
this is
there's a period there
yeah
and it feels hollow and hopeless
and after
seven months nine months of
oh my gosh mom's sick to pancreatic
cancer to hey she's got three months two
hey i'm having a baby two now you've got
a five month old and you said it you
know
you you said it's so great
the smoke is starting to clear on the
chaos
and now there's this reality right
it's kind of like you get by an
adrenaline a cortisol for a year and all
of a sudden
you wake up and the tornado the sun came
up the next day and the tornado came
through and there's no more house and
now you're just looking at the yard and
i don't know what to do now
yeah the first part of that is
that moment this is
and that's the hardest heartbreaking
you're there right
it feels hopeless you love that little
kid and you just want
to have that picture of your mom holding
him
and you should have that picture and
you're not
right yeah
so what does grief look like for you
right now do you have a you have a gang
do you have a crew you've got
to look like i mean i think
that's part of it is we're
i believe my husband and i have moved
every year for the last six years um
yeah it's hard when i
when i went on my
maternity leave from work
um there was a
like an acquisition and
everybody i knew at work quit
um you know so it's like i go back and
don't know anybody yeah um
so
we're
yeah just trying to
plug in somewhere has been really hard
with covid too so hard yeah
so let me um
can i give you a couple of ideas
yeah
yeah
um
you may have done this maybe not i say
this all the time and
um even i start to roll my eyes sometime
but it's so healing
if you haven't already
um
start a 30 day i'm going to write my mom
a letter every day
yeah just you and you can put it in what
i would do if i was you
is i'd get a special journal i'd
probably overpay for one go buy like a
nice leather journal
and
i want those letters to be something
that you pass along to your son
so that he can see him
one of the greatest gifts you're gonna
give him in the future
is a record of how my mom loved
how my mom grieved
how my mom took care of me and some of
her darkest moments
and it's going to be hard to remember
that kind of stuff in five years and 10
years and 20 years
a raw journal of the season i lost my
mom
will be a transformative gift for your
for generations right it'll be a legacy
gift
it's one of those meaning making things
and in this journal you'll probably be
heartbroken you'll probably be mad at
your mom for getting sick you'll be mad
at your dad because he's different
you'll all those things are going to be
real and raw and painful but what
they're going to do is they're going to
give you right now that's all sitting
right on top of your heart
and the more you write it the more
there's becomes this tiny little
distance
between that hurt those
waves and you
and right now it feels like it's all you
and it is yeah but you're gonna give
yourself some space there and then maybe
after 30 days you go to once a week
letter
and i want you to continue to reach out
to ask those questions
in this journal
mom he's got a weird rash i need some
help and you're not here
right yeah mom he will not
stop asking for snacks
help me or
uh he's five months old and husband's
already like so are we gonna start to
you know
mom yeah yeah
what do i write i want all that stuff
written down
and
she'll still be with you in those
moments
the second thing is this
give me one quick thing that your mom
loved
what brought her joy what was her
mission in life
um
i mean she
she worked in
healthcare too and just um
i mean her patients just loved her um
she
you know i still get
random little facebook messages from
former patients of hers and
i think she really just changed a lot of
people's lives
so here's a cool thing
as you're as you're able to and it's
going to feel like you're panning back
from a picture the grief right now feels
like you're at in the ocean and you're
treading water
over time it will feel like you're
walking through a creek
it's always gonna be wet right but it
will feel less overwhelming it'll feel
less
um like you're not gonna make it through
the next moment okay
you're gonna find these seasons of
meaning making these moments where
i'm gonna write every patient of hers
that i ever heard just let them know
that they blessed my mom too
or i'm going to begin to make little
bracelets what's your mom's name
savannah i'm going to make little
bracelets that says savannah cares and
i'm going to give them to all my
patients and let them know
there's a legacy of care in my family
and i'm gonna take care of you or if you
are dealing with pediatrics and you can
tell a mom or a dad whose kid is sick
and they're scared i'm gonna give you
this
um bracelet with my mom's name on it
it's a reminder that my whole family has
always cared about you guys right and it
becomes these moments of ways you can
honor your mom and make meaning of your
mom and at the same time
this is the hardest one you can let her
go
yeah and that will be seasons of
taking her clothes to donation places
that will be saying we don't need every
other piece of furniture that will mean
we right as you work through some of
those things what are the things that
are meaning making what are the things
that are important and what are they
gonna let mom go
all right i'm gonna let her go and
that's not a thing you do today that's
the thing you do over time
and the final thing here please please
please
you are exhausted you've got some
knuckleheaded husband he's probably
awesome i'll give you that
um
a five-month-old
and a dad who's dealing with his own
trauma
please please
do what you can to get connected in your
community
yeah you cannot do this by yourself
and that's not a thing to like guilt on
to be like well i got another chore to
do today i gotta make out with this guy
i gotta feed a five-month-old and now i
gotta go make a friend it's not like
that but kind of
kind of it is right
please go get involved in a local church
go get with a mom's group or a grief
group or a
lost my mom from cancer i guarantee you
there will be a group there in san jose
i guarantee it join a jogging group or
something but get a crew okay
yeah
walking through this by yourself is is
not tenable you can't do it you can
but it's gonna be hard to heal and we're
looking at legacy now
but i want tonight to be the night you
go get some silly overpaid priced fancy
leather journal or i don't know if you
like i don't know what you put on things
um sunshine's or
i don't know unicorns i don't care
whatever some stamped cool other thing
um and make your first letter tonight
and it can just start with mom i miss
you and i need you here you're not here
and it might be a short letter it might
be a really long one but commit to 30
days
to writing your mom letters if you're a
gangster and you're from san jose so
maybe if you're a gangster you can read
these to your husband
grief demands a witness you can read
them to him
maybe not maybe not
but if you did it'd be cool and maybe he
misses your mom too maybe he needs to
get a journal also you see i miss i miss
my mother-in-law he'll be one of seven
or eight people who've ever uttered that
sentence in all of world's history but
he might right he might really miss her
hearts are with you so sorry for your
loss
so sorry for the healing you got to do
so sorry that you're
mom
your little boy's gonna grow up without
grandma
this is
and what's next is where are you going
to shine the light where are you going
to honor your mom make meaning of this
senseless loss
and where are you going to begin to turn
the lights on
find the sunshine find beauty
we're with you